bill - going yeah bill congratulations
you the announcement yesterday must been
really exciting for you guys
huge announcements we revealed a car to
the world of an in-game car now an
actual car that's normally saved for car
shows like Geneva and in Paris yeah we
revealed a car here at e3 the Porsche
911 gt2 RS to the world yesterday was
awesome you know I've got the chance to
play the previous sports of motorsport
games and they always struck me as a
racing game not focused on being
cartoonish or strapping guns to the car
it's about hyper realistic racing
Fortson motorsport is about precision
it's about competition and we've rebuilt
Fortson motorsport seven from the ground
up to really recreate that feeling of
driving a car at peak the cars we have
over 700 cars every single one of them
they're going to rattle and shake it's
going to scare the crap out of you what
are some of the things that you've done
to bring that experience to PC well
going to PC has been awesome not only
will have mouse and keyboard support but
with multi USB we have every fan
requested wheel on the market and it's
been exciting for the team a lot of us
let me tell you and we've been testing
that last week alone we brought in any
USB device we had and we played on a
Guitar Hero guitar and a ger pad now
you're not going to do that obviously
that's not how real racing would that's
not the hyper-realistic quartet whatever
you have in your closet plug it in
you're ready to go
now what about for low-end pcs there's
obviously a lot of people who are on
budget devices I mean what about for
them what's the optimization been like
well it's been great going to the high
end of 4k unlock framerate 21 by 9 but
we've also lowered our min spec as well
to include i-5 and no matter where you
play it looks and plays great and
speaking of looking and playing great
you're here at e3 and I understand you
have some out-of-control rigs that
people can actually play the games on
absolutely come by the show we've got
two hydraulic rigs in 4k on ultra 4k P
select rigs you tell me that yeah bring
the vomit bag and come on check it out
it looks awesome well awesome bill
thanks so much and sharing with thank
you thank you everybody